Google cardboard has been cool since
forever
it took this sort of out there
technology that most of us thought
wouldn't land in our laps for quite a
while and made it really really easy to
use
not to mention affordable and now it has
a formidable ally in the new york times
which just released its own cardboard
app and sent units to subscribers a
variety of stories from the times now
come with a VR component giving readers
or viewers a virtual experience that
complements the stories if you were one
of the lucky people or are inspired to
pick up your own unit there are a couple
of other apps worth downloading sisters
is a first-person horror experience so
be prepared to scare yourself a little
while you navigate a very creepy old
house hell-bent on terrifying you if
that's just a little too passive and
horrifying zombie shooter VR is the
Walking Dead come to almost life where
you roam an abandoned subway system
taking out the undead if you want
something just a little more experienced
all without the jolt of adrenaline
Traverse which is a VR video catalog for
iPhone that includes a huge variety of
content everything from more New York
Times coverage to behind-the-scenes
footage of SNL monologues while there's
definitely a larger catalogue of
cardboard content for Android phones
what's available for iPhone is
definitely growing which means that no
matter what smartphone you've got the
world of VR is getting better and bigger
and at least with cardboard cheaper